Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute machen wir einen Blechkuchen, der von jedem geliebt wird.
Ihr kennt diese Klassiker. Diese Blechkuchen, die man sich so ansieht:
Schoko, Pudding-Schicht und Schoko. Und man liebt sie!
(H: Einfach einfach! Total einfach!)
Einfach einfach! Man liebt sie einfach! Also ich hab jetzt gedacht wir machen jetzt
(H: Einfach!)
wir machen jetzt einen solchen Blechkuchen.
Und der geht auch sehr schnell und ist sehr, sehr unkompliziert in der Zubereitung.
Ihr bräuchtet im Prinzip noch nicht mal eine Küchenmaschine
und könntet auch kräftig mit dem Schneebesen rühren.
Aber ich erleichtere mir jetzt einfach mal die Arbeit und geb die Eier in die Maschine,
geb Zucker mit dazu und lasse das dann so ungefähr eine Minute lang verrühren.
(H: Einfach einfach!)
Einfach einfach!
So, nach der Minute einmal Sonnenblumenöl mit reingeben und ganz kurz mit einrühren lassen.
Und jetzt kommen schon die trockenen Zutaten zum Einsatz.
Hier habe ich Mehl, Backkakao und Backpulver.
Und das verrühre ich immer gerne vorher miteinander, damit sich das besser vermengt.
Und dann siebe ich das zur Masse.
So, die trockenen Zutaten auch nur ganz kurz unterrühren,
nicht zu lange, damit erreicht ihr nur den gegenteiligen Effekt.
Wir wollen ja, dass der Teig richtig schön lecker und saftig wird. Und den gebe ich jetzt
in meine vorbereitet - in meinem vorbereiteten Backrahmen,
den habe ich hier eingestellt auf 28 x 22 cm.
(H: Ist das der mit der Klemmung?)
Jaa!
(H: Ein bisschen Werbung machen!)
Und genau! Der Teig - ihr könnt das sehen - der ist etwas, ich sag mal klebriger als normal.
Das ist kein gewöhnlicher Biskuitteig, das sowieso nicht
weil wir ja Fett dazu gegeben haben. Dann schön glatt streichen
und bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze backen. Der Hamza schreibt euch die ganz genaue Backzeit rein,
ich schätze mal so um die 15min.
Den fertig gebackenen Boden habe ich jetzt ungefähr 5-6min lang ein bisschen ausdampfen lassen
damit er nicht ganz so heiß ist und jetzt müssen wir ihn einmal umdrehen.
Das heißt wir nehmen ihn jetzt einmal gleich raus aus dem Backrahmen,
drehen ihn um und machen dann den Backrahmen wieder drauf.
So, jetzt sind wir startklar für die Milchtränke, dafür nehme ich mir einfach Milch,
die ist jetzt ganz einfach aus dem Kühlschrank, die müsst ihr auch nicht erwärmen.
Der Kuchen ist allerdings noch lauwarm und jetzt tränke ich ihn gleichmäßig mit der Milch .
Oah, ich liebe auch diesen Part, der wird euch auch richtig viel Spaß machen!
(H: Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Trilece!)
M-hm, stimmt!
So, der durchtränkte Boden, der bleibt jetzt erstmal der Seite liegen
und wir machen weiter mit der Pudding-Schicht!
Dafür habe ich hier Milch in meinem Kochtopf und geb da jetzt die anderen Zutaten mit dazu.
Und ihr findet die ganz genauen Mengenangaben immer unten in der...?
(H: Infobox!)
Infobox, genau! So, jetzt gebe ich da Zucker mit dazu für die Süße, Vanille für den Geschmack.
Und ich mache jetzt eine -
(H: Mach ruhig bisschen mehr!)
Okay, ich mache eine Mischung aus Vanillepuddingpulver,
könnt ihr auch stattdessen Speisestärke nehmen.
Und Mehl, das liegt einfach dann, also das -
jetzt hab ich mich verhaspelt!
Ähm genau, ich mache das wegen der Konsistenz,
weil wenn ihr nur Speisestärke nehmt, habt ihr eine ganz andere Konsistenz
als wenn ihr einen Teil davon durch Mehl ersetzt.
Und später, nachdem wir das Ganze unter Rühren aufkochen lassen haben, kommt noch Butter mit dazu.
So, erst nachdem das jetzt klümpchenfrei verrührt wurde, schaltet ihr den Herd ein
und dann immer weiter rühren.
So, der Pudding ist eingedickt, den Herd hab ich jetzt ausgeschaltet
und jetzt einfach noch die Butter einrühren.
Und den Pudding dann einfach auf den Schokoboden verteilen und richtig schön glattstreichen.
So und jetzt muss es ja nur noch auskühlen und fest werden,
das dauert so ungefähr, ich würde sagen eine Stunde bis eineinhalb.
Es kommt halt immer darauf an. Erstmal auf Zimmertemperatur abkühlen lassen,
nichts heißes in den Kühlschrank stellen und dann eben noch mal in den Kühlschrank legen.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder für den Abschluss. Bis gleich!
So, jetzt ist bei mir alles abgekühlt und ich mache die letzte Schicht: die Schokoglasur.
Ich persönlich mag jetzt bei dem Rezept Vollmilchkuvertüre.
Ihr könntet auch 1:1 einfach Zartbitterkuvertüre nehmen, das ist
vollkommen euch überlassen.
(H: Ich mag Zartbitter, was machen wir jetzt?!)
Oh-oh! Moment, es gibt kurz einen Ehestreit! Hamza, mach kurz die Kamera aus, ich muss mit dir schimpfen!
*Kampfgeräusche*
Nein, Hamza ist so lieb und hat gesagt wir nehmen jetzt Vollmilch !
Okay. So, jetzt bin ich hier an meinem Herd und erhitze Sahne.
Und nicht aufkochen lassen, nur erhitzen!
Wenn ihr merkt es wird langsam warm, es will gerade hochsteigen,
dann den Herd ausschalten und die gehackte Kuvertüre rein geben.
So, und jetzt muss nur noch die Glasur anziehen und dann können wir servieren!
Beziehungsweise wir haben noch ein paar Stunden bis zum Fastenbrechen
aber ihr müsst jetzt nicht noch mal unnötig lange kühlen.
Und... alles in allem, wie lange haben wir jetzt gebraucht?
Ohne Kühlzeit!
(H: Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr!)
Ohne Kühlzeit vielleicht 30-40min wenn man gaaanz langsam ist.
(H: Wenn man fastet hat man gar kein Zeitgefühl, finde ich!)
Ja, man verliert das Zeitgefühl beim Fasten, das stimmt! Auf jeden Fall werde ich das noch
dekorieren mit Erdbeeren weil wir gerade Saison haben und ich finde sieht immer schick aus.
Vielleicht nehme ich ja noch Pistazien dazu oder Kokosraspeln.
Wir machen das einfach ganz spontan nachher. So und euch entlasse ich schonmal.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr diesem Video-
(H: *lacht* Wie in der Schule, was?)
Wie in der Schule, ne? Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr dem Video ein Däumchen nach oben gebt.
Genau und einen Kommentar schreibt vielleicht-
(H: Und uns auf Instagram folgt!)
Jaa, auf Instagram müsst ihr uns sowieso folgen, das wäre ganz toll!
Und vielleicht habt ihr auch Vorschläge, was wir als nächstes Schönes machen können,
schreibt's gerne immer wieder rein und dann schreiben wir auch miteinander in den Kommentaren.
(H: Und geht mal schön hier diese Backform kaufen, die ist hammer!)
Die ist der Knüller! Aber dazu müssen wir eigentlich sogar mal ein extra Infovideo machen,
weil da gibt's so viel zu erzählen!
(H: Supportet uns!)
Genau! Also bis dann ihr Lieben, Tschüss!